let's do some order of operations
problems and for the sake of time I'll
do every other problems let's start with
one B 1 B right there they have 2 plus 7
times 11 minus 12 divided by 3 so just
remember the top priority is always
going to be your parentheses so you have
your parentheses let me write it this
way
your top priority is going to be your
parentheses after that you're going to
have your exponents your exponents after
that you have multiplying and dividing
and after that you have addition and
subtraction so let's remember that and
tackle these order of operations
problems so priority there's no
parentheses here there's no exponents
here so the priority is going to go to a
multiplication and division so you could
do view this as being equivalent to 2
since we're going to our multiplication
before we do any addition or subtraction
and we're going to do our division
before doing any addition or subtraction
problem 1b is exactly equivalent to this
the parentheses are just I'm reinforcing
the notion that I'm going to do my
multiplication and division my
multiplication and division before I do
the addition and the subtraction so 7
times 11 is 77 and then you have a and
then 12 divided by 3 is 4 and then the
rest of the problem was 2 Plus this
thing which is 77 minus this thing and
here since everything is in addition or
subtraction let's just go left to right
left to right 2 plus 77 is 79 minus 4
which is equal to 75 so 1 B is equal to
75 let's do 1 D this is a nice hairy
problem right there so 1 D it says 2
times 3 plus 2 minus 1 closing two
parentheses all of that over 4 minus 6
two minus three minus five let's see if
we can simplify this a little bit as we
said parentheses take our priority so
let's do the parentheses first 2 minus 1
2 minus 1 is just 1 3 minus 5 that is
minus 2 or negative 2 I should say 6
plus 2 is 8 is 8 now let's keep looking
at the parentheses or see where we can
simplify things we have this parenthesis
right here so 3 plus this one is now
going to be equal to 4 actually let me
rewrite it so where I have 2 times this
whole expression 3 plus 1 so it's 2
times 4 that right there is 4 all of
that over 4 minus 8 that's negative 4
all right this right here is negative 4
and then minus this negative 2 minus
negative 2 2 times 4 is 8 so this whole
thing simplifies to well and an 8 a
minus of a negative that's just the plus
of the plus the negatives cancel out so
this whole thing simplifies to 8 divided
by negative 4 is negative 2 plus 2 plus
2 so it equals 0 so this is big hairy
thing simplified to 0 now let's do to be
to be let me clear some space here to be
I'll leave the order of operations stuff
there let me clear that and let me clear
this all right to be to be evaluate the
following expressions involving
variables fair enough so they wrote 2y
squared and they're saying that X is
equal to 1 which is irrelevant because
there is no X here and Y is equal to 5
so if Y is equal to 5 this thing becomes
the same thing as 2 times 5 squared 2
times 5 squared and notice I
put parentheses there I could have
written this as this is the same thing
as 2 times 5 squared and if you look at
the order of operations exponents take
priority over multiplication that's why
in my head I just automatically put
those parentheses we're going to do the
exponent first so this is 25 so you get
2 times 25 is equal to 50 and so that is
2 B this is equal to use some darker
color that is equal to 50 let's do 2 D 2
D all right they're giving us Y squared
minus X whole thing squared X is equal
to 2 and Y is equal to 1 well we just
substitute where we see why we put a 1
so this is going to be 1 squared minus x
squared X is 2 minus 2 I'm sorry minus X
naught x squared so we just put a
regular X there that's where you put a 2
and then all of that squared well 1
squared is just 1 so that is just 1 1
minus 2 so 1 minus 2 is negative 1
negative 1 and then we're going to want
to square our negative 1 so that will be
equal to positive 1 so that is equal to
1 negative times the negative is a
positive
all right let's do 3 B 3 B 3 B doing
every other problem I'll do it in yellow
evaluate the following expressions
involving variables all right same idea
so they're giving us 4x over 9x squared
Oh actually I said I'll do 3 B I was
doing 3a so here we go we have Z squared
over X plus y plus x squared over X
minus y and they're telling us that X is
equal to 1 Y is equal to negative 2 and
Z is equal to 4 so let's just do our
substitutions
first so Z squared that's the same thing
as all in a different color four squared
over X 1 plus y negative 2 plus x
squared that's 1 squared over X which is
1 minus y Y is negative 2
so this is going to be equal to 4
squared is 16 over 1 plus negative 2
that's 1 minus 2 which is negative 1
plus 1 squared which is 1 over 1 minus
negative 2 that's the same thing as 1
plus plus 2 plus 1/3 and so this will be
16 divided by negative 1 we can write
that as that's equal to negative 16 plus
1/3 now if we want to actually add these
as fractions we could have a common
denominator negative 16 is the same
thing as minus 48 over 3 or negative 48
over 3 right if you take 48 divided by 3
you'll get 16 and I'm just keeping the
negative sign and then you had you add
that plus 1/3 we have a common
denominator now 3 negative 48 plus 1 is
negative 47 negative 47 so our answer is
negative 47 over 3 problem 3 D 3 3 D
same type of situation x squared minus Z
squared over X Z minus 2 x times Z minus
X X is equal to negative 1 Z is equal to
3 let's do our substitution so this is x
squared that's minus 1 squared minus Z
squared so minus 3 squared all of that
Oh
x times Z X times Z is minus 1 times 3
minus 2 times X X is negative 1 times Z
minus x times 3 minus X X is negative 1
all right minus X wherever we saw an X
we put a minus 1 so this is going to be
equal to remember you do your exponents
first
well parentheses first then exponents so
we have negative 1 squared that's just a
positive 1 3 squared that's just a
positive 9 so our numerator becomes 1
minus 9 that's minus 8 or negative 8 and
then our denominator negative 1 times 3
is negative 3 and then let's see let's
go to our parentheses here we have 3
minus negative 1 that's the same thing
as 3 plus +1 so that right there becomes
4 so our denominator becomes negative 3
minus 2 times negative 1 times 4 so
that's negative 8 minus negative 8 minus
of a negative is the same thing as a
plus so this whole thing becomes
negative 8 over negative 8 plus 8 sorry
negative 3 plus 8 is 5 so it's negative
8/5 minus 8 over 5 all right let me
clear some space just so we can
reference this problem properly let me
clear all of this out of the way let's
do problems these are interesting now
problem 4 insert parentheses and you
just expression to make it a true
equation fascinating alright so for B
you have 12 divided by 4 plus 10 minus 3
times 3 plus 7 is equal to 11 so let's
see what happens if we just do
traditional order of operations and I'll
do a little bit of in my head because
it's gonna take some experimentation
what did I this is 4 B 12 divided by 4
yep
the problem so if we did 12/4 first and
we would get three so let me just do
this in yellow so if we did regular
order of operations this would be a
three this right here would be a nine so
you would have three plus 10 which is 13
minus 9 13 minus 9 is 4 plus 7 actually
that seems right let me make sure I did
that right 3 plus 10 right that looks
right so we really just have to do
regular order of operations so it
already looks like a true equation so if
you do 12 divided by 4 plus 10 minus 3
times 3 plus 7 I think it turns out
right let me confirm make sure I'm not
making a mistake 12 divided by 4 is 3
plus 10 minus 3 times 3 is 9 plus 7 this
is equal to 13 minus 9 which is equal to
so all of this is equal to 13 minus 9 is
equal to 4 plus 7 is indeed equal to 11
so that one wasn't too bad you actually
wouldn't have to put any parentheses to
make this a true expression you just
have to follow the order of operations
but throwing those parentheses there it
makes it a little bit easier to read
let's try 4 d 4 d 12 minus 8 minus 4
times 5 is equal to minus 8 so first
let's just see what happens if we did
traditional order of operations if we
did traditional order of operations we
would do this 4 times 5 first which
would give us 20 over there and then we
would have 12 minus 8 12 minus 8 is 4
and then we would do 4 minus 20 no
that's not right that would give us
negative 16 so that's not going to be
right so we can't just do traditional
order of operations sorry this is a
minus 8 right there so let's see how we
can experiment with this what if we put
let's try out a couple of situations
what if we did 12 minus 8
- four and then multiply that times five
let's see what this gives us I'm just
experimenting with parentheses so if you
do eight minus four that right there
would be 8 minus 4 is 4 and then 4 times
5 would be 20 and then 12 minus 20 yeah
that works so let me confirm that
so I'm saying I'm gonna put parentheses
right there and right there and let's
work it out you would get 8 minus 4 is 4
so this whole thing would simplify to 12
minus 4 times 5 and you just do order of
operations you do multiplication first
so that is just 20 and if I wanted to
make it very clear I could actually
write it like this I could actually put
another round of parentheses right like
that but order of operations would tell
us to do it anyway so it becomes 12
minus 20 which is indeed minus 8 or
negative 8